wie gehen unsere noch lebenden Kanzler
in die Geschichte ein Gerd Schröder
müssen wir nicht drüber reden hat er
überhaupt noch einen deutschen Pass
keine Ahnung keine Ahnung für Angela
Merkel gab es diese Woche einen Orden zu
dem kommen wir gleich und für Olaf
Scholz einen neuen
Untersuchungsausschuss ja wegen seiner
anhaltenden Gedächtnislücken in Sachen
warburgbank
dass man in diesem Land mit so einer
schlimmen Krankheit trotzdem Kanzler
werden kann
er kann ja nichts dafür dass er gar
nichts mehr weiß was in drei Gesprächen
mit einem cumex Banker gesagt wurde er
könnte sich an Details nicht erinnern er
kann sich an nichts erinnern er kann
sich einfach an Details konkret nicht
erinnern er könnte sich weder an das
Treffen selbst noch an den Inhalt der
treffen erinnern daran kann ich mich
nicht erinnern und er kann sich auch
nicht an die Treffen selbst erinnern
woran konnte er sich erinnern ich bin
Olaf Scholz
ist doch toll cumex also sich vom Staat
Steuern mehrfach zurückholen ist ein
Raubzug auf Kosten der Allgemeinheit und
die Frage aller Fragen lautet immer noch
hat da jemand politisch Einfluss
genommen als Hamburg damals auf 47
Millionen cum exkohle verzichten wollte
sicher ist Scholz hat als Bürgermeister
den Warburg Boss Christian olearius also
ein mutmaßlichen Steuerbetrüger als
gegen den bereits ermittelt wurde
mehrmals in seinen Diensträumen
empfangen aber beweist das schon dass er
sich politisch eingemischt hat das muss
man sich
vor wie log
ische Vorgang wie blöd müssen denn diese
Banker gewesen sein dass Olaf Scholz ihn
dreimal hintereinander stundenlang
erklären musste dass er sich in diesem
Fall nicht einmischen darf
und kann doch sein und gibt doch
wahnsinnig blöde Banker oder olearius
ist in dem Gespräch mit Scholz jedes Mal
eingepennt und es musste wiederholt
werden sondern auch schon passiert
Scholz ist ein immer top vorbereiteter
aktenfresser weiß aber gar nichts mehr
über seine Gespräche zum größten
Steuerbetrug Hamburgs der eigentliche
Skandal bleibt der Umgang mit dem
Skandal es gibt dann nur ein Treffen zu
und sagt ja da wurden bestimmte Themen
besprochen dann tauchen weitere Passagen
aus dem Tagebuch von uliarius auf Scholz
muss drei Treffen zugeben und kann sich
seitdem an kein einziges Thema mehr
erinnern ein medizinisches Wunder
der Mann ist nur Kanzler geworden weil
cumex so kompliziert ist wir Deutschen
mögen unsere Skandale einfach wer da
abgelacht den wähle ich nicht hier jetzt
nicht im heute-show AppStore hol dir
jetzt das mai Olaf Fotobuch für Momente
an die du dich nie mehr erinnern willst
zum Beispiel an damals als G20
Randalierer Hamburg abgefackelt haben
wer war da noch mal verantwortlich wer
wollte SPD-Chef werden und hat ernsthaft
gegen Essen und Nova verloren mal
ehrlich es könnte jeder gewesen sein und
wie hieß noch mal die eine Bank wo du
nie warst und auch mit keinem geredet
hast und wenn doch einer nachfragt sagst
du einfach
entschuldigung das mai Olaf Fotobuch für
deine schönsten erinnerungslitten 10%
Rabatt mit dem Gutscheincode hä keine
Ahnung weiß ich doch nicht mehr
perfekt
das perfekte Geschenk wenn sie mal
wieder ihren Hochzeitstag vergessen
haben meine klar benutzt die Union den
neuen Untersuchungsausschuss als
politische Waffe andererseits ist der
Olaf auch selber schuld es soll er halt
mal was glaubwürdiges Aussagen frag mich
gerade gabs vom Kanzler eigentlich in
letzter Zeit auf irgendeine Frage meine
klare Antwort ist Olaf Scholz gerne
Döner klar mir schmecken die jedenfalls
schon sehr lange und ich esse gerne
Döner
prima hätten wir das doch wenigstens
geklärt bin mal gespannt was da noch
rauskommt demnächst beginnt ja in Bonn
der große Prozess gegen olearius
allerdings ist Herr Scholz aktuell nicht
der einzige Kanzler mit imagekrise auch
Angela Merkels Regentschaft wird
plötzlich sehr kritisch gesehen sehr
kritisch
da heißt jetzt nur noch 16 Jahre
Stillstand Abhängigkeit von Russland die
ist jetzt voll die böse und kriegt
trotzdem diese Woche das sogenannte
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens in
besonderer Ausführung sieht allerdings
schon aus als hätte Steinmeier mal
schnell ein Weihnachtsstern auf eine
alte Krawatte getackert
und wo wir gerade beim bundesu sind
Steinmeier steht auch in der Kritik
wegen Russland weshalb kritiker sagen er
habe sich bei der Veranstaltung quasi
selber einen umgehängt allerdings hat er
vorher müssen wir ihm lassen noch eine
sehr nette Merkel Laudatio gehalten und
weil es unmöglich war in einer in einem
solchen Rahmen auf die Rede von
Steinmeier politisch inhaltlich zu
antworten hat sie sich ihm entschieden
den Menschen zu danken die ihren 60
Jahren Kanzlerschaft an der Seite
gestanden haben
ich muss zugeben so lange ist es mir
auch vorgekommen
die Gästeliste im Schloss Bellevue war
super exklusiv so ein ganz harte Tür nur
eine Handvoll Leute waren geladen
darunter zum Beispiel Jürgen Klinsmann
warum nicht war ein sehr guten dritten
Platz bei der WM 2006 geholt aber es ist
natürlich schon eine totale Demütigung
für Friedrich Merz stell dir mal vor
cleans Mann da rein aber du nicht
ja ja aber der März hat sich trotzdem
riesig gefreut über den Orden für Merkel
er kann es halt nur nicht so zeigen
heute bekommt der Frau Merkel diesen
höchsten Bergen als dritte CDU-Kanzlerin
er fühlt sie das mit Stolz wir haben das
als
Bundesvorstand und auch ich als
Parteivorsitzender nicht zu bewerten und
zu beurteilen
entnehmen Sie meine grenzenlose Freude
einfach diesem Gesicht
große Teile der CDU sind gerade dabei
sich von Merkel zu distanzieren vor
allem wegen Atomausstieg und wegen
Flüchtlingspolitik auch in unserer
Abhängigkeit vom russischen Gas ist die
Frau neuerdings komplett alleine schuld
das ist einerseits Unsinn andererseits
hat sie uns entscheidende Fakten zu
Putin leider erst als Rentnerin verraten
ich weiß noch sehr wie ich oft mit
Leuten gesagt habe ihr wisst dass er
Europa zerstören will er will die
Europäische Union zerstören weil er sie
als Vorstufe zur NATO sieht ich wusste
das alles und habe trotzdem zwei
eingetütet weil ich konnte
auch nach all den Jahren wird diese
Imitation nicht besser meine Damen und
Herren zur Wahrheit gehört wir alle wir
alle wollten billiges Gas aus Russland
er wo war denn der große mediale
Aufschrei gegen Nord Stream Merkel
spiegelt die deutsche Gesellschaft wir
haben es uns alle zusammen muckelig
gemacht in ihrem alternativlosen weiter
so Land ne ist das so war das ja ja 12
Jahre übrigens liebevoll begleitet von
der SPD die jetzt so tut als hätte sie
für alle Kokos eine Alibi ne klar Angela
Merkel hat viel liegen lassen erklärt
auch die Liedauswahl für ihren
Zapfenstreich
endlich im Handel der ungekürzte
Zapfenstreich für Angela Merkel mit all
den Hits die später rausgeschnitten
wurden nach du hast den Farbfilm
vergessen gab's nämlich noch du hast ein
neuer Energie
du hast die Digitalisierung vergessen
du hast die Bildung vergessen
du hast die Bundeswehr vergessen
[Musik]
jetzt zum Vergessen 11 endlose Stunden
auf 18 CDs und als Bonustrack die Probe
für den schulzapfenstreich ich habe die
Warburg Bank vergessen ist doch egal
[Musik]
stimmen muss ich lohnen so meine Damen
und Herren
was man Angela Merkel aber rückblickend
wirklich lassen muss sie hat sich nie in
den Vordergrund gespielt skandalfrei
integer uneitel nicht selbstverständlich
heutzutage womit wir nahtlos beim Markus
Söder werden ja ja der König der
Selbstvermarktung hat ist diese Woche
wieder als Aufmacher in sämtliche Medien
geschafft mit einer absoluten
Nichtmeldung jeder will in meiner Isar 2
in Bayern in Eigenregie weiter betreiben
dazu sollte der Bund das Atomgesetz
ändern
ja und ich will in hautengen Hosen gut
aussehen
geht aber nicht
Atomkraft baut da unten noch mehr
Biogasanlagen allein mit der Scheiße die
Söhne an einem Tag labert könnte man
ganz Franken wochenlang mit Strom
versorgen
[Applaus]
für ein neues Atomgesetz bräuchte es
wohl eine Verfassungsänderung warum
diskutieren wir trotzdem ernsthaft über
diesen Quatsch was stimmt nicht mit uns
als Medien das ist doch die Frage und
die gebe ich direkt weiter an Tina
hausten sie leitet die 300köpfige
spezialredaktion die sich bei uns
ausschließlich mit Markus Söder
relevanten Themen beschäftigt Tina warum
sind wir alle so besessen von dem Mann
ich weiß es doch auch nicht es ist wie
wie Essen bei McDonald's schon nach zwei
Bissen ist einem kotzübel aber dann kann
man nicht aufhören als auch irgendwie
ganz geil ist so das Währung ist
Aufmerksamkeit er hat als einziger
Begriffen wie eine Mediendemokratie
funktioniert
weiter so das News Alert gerade kommt
die Meldung rein Markus Söder hat sich
aus Protest am Rand des abklingenbeckens
von Isar 2
festgeklebt und der wird so lange die
Luft anhalten bis die Ampel sich bei ihm
entschuldigt für was für was sie fallen
schon wieder auf den Mann rein der will
doch gar kein eigenes AKW inklusive Müll
der will nur dass wir vergessen was er
quasi vorgestern noch über Atomunfälle
gesagt hat und die Folgen sind dann
einfach in einer Form dramatisch die
nicht mehr zu akzeptieren gewesen sind
dieses Risiko weiterzutragen hinzu kommt
noch das bis heute ja die ungelöste
Frage des Atommülls da steht ja also
sorry aber das ist
jetzt 20
da war der Markus fast noch ein Kind wir
lernen schließlich alle dazu und Sie
können doch nicht einfach so
Olga Oliver Söder News bitte nicht ich
erfahre gerade Markus Söder hat heute
festgestellt dass Bayern gar keinen
eigenen Überseehafen hat und fordert
deshalb einen direkten Zugang zum Meer
und hier sehen wir auch schon live
Bilder vom ersten Spatenstich für den
sogenannten Augsburg post-kanal
dafür geschlafen hat Bayern Teile von
Hessen und Niedersachsen Thüringen wird
komplett geflutet und in einen Stausee
zur bayerischen Trinkwasserversorgung
umgebaut ja genau und so geht das jetzt
ununterbrochen weiter bis zum 8 oktober
dem Tag der bekackten Bayern Wahl ich
halte das nicht aus ja Oliver ich weiß
eigentlich dürfen wir über sowas gar
nicht mehr berichten aber es ist halt
die eine Droge ich will wirklich
aufhören aber dann gucke ich wieder auf
mein Handy und sehe
heute gibt's auch noch mal
die schmeckt super gibt Kraft und für
die politischen Gegner es wird ein
harter Tag heute
der weiß was das Volk sehen will und
nach jedem tiktok Video fühlt man sich
wie frisch
durchgesödert
mir reicht's für heute vielen Dank Klaus
wir machen jetzt mal einen kalten Entzug
sie melden sich nur noch wenn was
wirklich wichtiges passiert natürlich
ich meine und diese simple ständige die
Spinnen da in Berlin das funktioniert
auch noch es funktioniert in Umfragen
steht Söder nämlich schon wieder
irgendwo zwischen 40 und 42 %. übrigens
hat er im letzten Jahr nur an fünf von
30 bayerischen Landtagssitzung
teilgenommen weil er wohl komplett
ausgelastet ist mit neuen Fischbrötchen
Videos
ich werde wirklich nicht stören wenn es
nicht extrem wichtig wäre sie glauben
nicht welche exklusive News gerade
eingeplant ist
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aus unserer bürgerspezialredaktion so ja
ich meine es ist ja so
die Ampel macht der Opposition natürlich
auch leicht mit ihrem dauerzoff ich sage
nur Heizung tatsächlich gibt es nur noch
ein Projekt bei dem sie einer Meinung
sind richtig die Sache mit dem Kiffen
gut
ja das ist nicht das wichtigste Thema
der Welt aber symptomatisch für den
Zustand der Regierung denn selbst dazu
können sie ihre Versprechen nicht halten
von wegen legales Cannabis in
lizenzierten Shops ab 2023 ich hatte
mich so gefreut auf Fachgeschäfte mit
kreativen Namen wie Galeria Hof
the piano
Günthers Gras und natürlich
Heimatmuseum nichts wird nein nichts
wird dürfen erstmal nicht eröffnen dabei
war die Vorfreude riesengroß sogar bei
der ARD
wann Bubert legal
sorry ich bin total dicht ich habe nicht
zugehört
Otterbach und Cem Özdemir haben letzte
Woche in einer PK vorgestellt was noch
übrig bleibt vom legalisierungstraum ja
nicht viel muss man sagen nicht viel
immerhin wird endkriminalisiert bis zu
25 Gramm für den Eigengebrauch sind
demnächst erlaubt außerdem darf sich
jeder Erwachsene maximal drei weibliche
Pflanzen zu Hause ins Gemüsebeet setzen
ja männliche sind wohl vollkommen
nutzlos
ja wie bei den Küken im Grunde ähm was
muss ich sonst noch wissen pro Monat 50
Gramm bei den unter 21-jähriges im
monatliche Obergrenze bei 30 Gramm also
zu sehen das können für den eigenen
Anbau 7 Samen oder fünf Stecklinge
bezogen werden
Stecklinge was soll das denn sein ich
Gärtner oder was ja so klingt
wahrscheinlich bald Gang meine Straße 7
Samen fünf Stecklinge mein Block
ach das ist deutsch ja Stecklinge sind
das Gimmick im neuen impfzeit
warum so furchtbar kompliziert und wer
soll das kontrollieren weil ernsthaft
wir können ja schlecht Polizisten in
private Gärten schicken zum Pflanzen
zählen bitte ach das tatsächlich der
Plan
alle Einheiten Zielpersonen betreten die
Terrasse ich zähle drei Pflanzen und
Moment fünf Stecklinge nee warte mal
neu bei VOX ab ins Bett die Kippers
laufen immer direkt
also jugendschutz ist schon sehr wichtig
denn es ist ja nachgewiesen was früher
Cannabiskonsum mit so Gehirn macht wobei
ich ehrlicherweise gar nicht gewusst
habe wie früh manche da anfangen dann
sensiblen Orten auch darauf lege ich
Wert wie Schulhöfen oder Kitas ist der
Konsum ausgeschlossen ja es ist ein
riesen Problem ein riesen Problem
dargestellt ne
jeden Tag 10 Stunden Mittagsschlaf
gut in Kitas darf also bald nicht mehr
gekifft werden ist schon mal sehr gut
und die Pläne der Ampel gehen ja noch
viel weiter weiß gar nicht ob Ihnen das
bekannt ist aber in Fußgängerzonen soll
das Kiffen aus Jugendschutzgründen erst
ab 20 Uhr erlaubt sein und das macht
total Sinn oder haben Sie jemals einen
Jugendlichen nach 20 Uhr in der Stadt
gesehen eben hier so läuft das dann bis
19:59 sieht alles noch ganz normal aus
aber punkt acht schmeißen alle die einen
Typen weg und holen die anderen Typen
raus das wird unser Stadtbild definitiv
verändert meine Damen und Herren
[Musik]
ja ja gut das ist eigentliche Problem
bleibt natürlich ungelöst einfach nur
endkriminalisieren reicht nämlich nicht
der Staat müsste wie in Kanada selber
anbauen kontrollieren und verkaufen
sonst freut sich am Ende nur das
organisierte Verbrechen geht aber bei
uns nicht wegen EU Recht und das war
auch von Anfang an klar aber es ist so
simpel das kapieren sogar heute schon
Reporter keiner kann uns sagen wie man
das EU Recht umgehen will es wird kommen
es wird tatsächlich kommen aber wenn die
wenn die Ampel rot ist und nicht mit dem
Auto drüber fahre hilft mir auch nichts
zu sagen ich habe aber eine gute
Rechtsabteilung kann Sie beruhigen es
wird zum Schluss kommen aber wenn sie
nicht kommen
ja die heute show verleiht daher heute
an die Lauterbach den Karl scheuer
Verdienstorden meine Damen und Herren
oder umgekehrt ist auch egal
sind gemeiner Vergleich scheuer hat uns
eine halbe Milliarde gekostet gut
Tatsache ist natürlich die bisherige
Drogenpolitik ist auch gescheitert 10%
der unter 18-Jährigen haben schon mal
gekifft und diese Zahl hat sich seit
2013 verdoppelt ich meine ist ja auch
kein Wunder alle paar Meter wird man von
zwielichtigen Drogendealern angequatscht
sogar beim Fernsehen hier nimm ein paar
Züge dann kannst du gut kacken
bei wirkt das so nett hat uns alle
getäuscht so und dieses Nebengeschäft
von Markus lands also den Schwarzmarkt
will die Ampel jetzt austrocknen und
zwar nach dem Prinzip Hoffnung dass sie
hofft dass sämtliche Kiffer in
Deutschland lernen wie man selber anbaut
ich habe ein gutes Gefühl oder oder man
geht den maximal uncoolenweg und wird
Mitglied in einem eingetragenen Kiffer
Verein ja sogenannte social Clubs sollen
bald entstehen stell mir das vor wie so
ein britischen Club zum Butler sagt
James die Financial Times und die Bong
bitte
maximal 500 Mitglieder sind da erlaubt
und ich denke da brauchst du schon ein
verdammt großes Gewächshaus das
obendrein gut gesichert sein muss denn
sonst klauen sie dir garantiert deine
Stecklinge oder den Samen ist doch
logisch natürlich wird das geklaut aber
wir wissen es nicht wer weiß
vielleicht gar nicht mehr retten vor
Mitglieds antreten ist ja auch eine
total spannende Mischung ne deutsche
Vereinsmeister
des Kleingartenvereins grüner Daumen in
Köln Nippes eine historische
Entscheidung steht an so hatten wir fest
der Typ von Parzelle 3 der nie aber
wirklich nie seinen Rasen vernünftig
mäht wird beim Ordnungsamt angezeigt
[Applaus]
nächster Tagesordnungspunkt und zwar die
Umwandlung unseres schönen Vereins in
den cannabis-club
was ja Günther wenn du mal endlich mal
neue junge Mitglieder haben wollen ja da
müssen wir mit der Zeit gehen die Kids
kriegst du heutzutage nicht mit deinem
blöden Brechbohnen
ich habe diesbezüglich ein paar
sogenannte Dübel mitgebracht ich wollte
sagen ich probieren wir jetzt mal also
was soll passiert
der erste Eindruck der Kleingärtner ist
sehr positiv
übernehmen ja klar mache ich gern dem
Vereinsvorsitzenden entgleitet die
Situation viel schneller als gedacht
guck mal ich Google hier gerade was man
sonst noch anbauen kann hast du schon
mal was von diesem
Heroin gehört klingt auch spannend die
Abwärtsspirale ist nicht mehr
aufzuhalten schon am nächsten Tag
schickt der Verein ein Mitglied auf den
Strich um Geld für neue Stecklinge zu
besorgen
und als der Club erfährt dass die
Rentner in der benachbarten
Gartenkolonie auch Cannabis anbauen
eskaliert die Situation vollends
vielen Dank auch Karl Lauterbach
zu Fuß gehen können so eine Scheiße
so klein geworden Kolonien übrigens nur
dass sie es wissen in Spanien sind
solche Clubs schon seit den 90ern
geduldet und da wurde der Schwarzmarkt
leider gar nicht zurückgedrängt reden
wir drüber mit einem Mann der ehrlich
gesagt immer ein bisschen wirkt als wäre
er bekifft dabei ist er ein ganz
normaler Alkoholiker oder Schubert
Botschaft schön dass du da bist bei
jungen Menschen ich sprach schon drüber
ist es tatsächlich so wenn die früh viel
kiffen dann macht das Sachen mit dem
Gehirn bis hin zu Psychosen was redest
du als mindestens fünffacher Vater man
kann es glaube ich nur schätzen was was
redest du anderen Eltern wie man die
Kinder fernhält von Drogen ja also das
Cannabis bei der Entwicklung des
Jugendlichen Gehirns schädlich ist das
ist bewiesen aber es ist ja noch nicht
bewiesen dass bei Jugendlichen also auch
in Folge dieses exzessiven mediens
überhaupt noch genug resthören vorhanden
ist
das Schaden nehmen könnte ja ist erstmal
eine quintethese und ich glaube insofern
finde ich diesen Zwangs
kollektivierungsgedanken mit der
Genossenschaft gar nicht so schlecht ich
glaube das hat ja den Effekt dass die
ganze kiefer-bagage dann so ein bisschen
gegenseitig sich behütet ja wenn die
dann zugedröhnt Auto fahren mit dann
wenn die dann mit mit 18 km/h durch die
Stadt
Rasen
dann ist es schon gut wenn dann der eine
sagt hier fahren wir rechts und dann
meinte andere ich denke du fährst ja
und ich glaube bei den ja bei eigenen
Kindern kann man glaube ich wirklich nur
mit Abschreckung arbeiten denn was
Drogen anrichten können das ist ja
wirklich bekannt ja es kann dazu führen
dass Menschen ihre Selbstkontrolle
komplett verlieren dass sie auch sage
ich mal wirklich ihre selbst würde ja
abgeben und zum Beweis gibt es ja da
wirklich im Internet jede Menge
erschreckende und auch abstoßende Filme
und Fotos von mir ähm und mehr kann ich
da wirklich nicht machen nein definitiv
geplatzt ist der Traum von deutschem
Gras als Exportschlager wie sich die FDP
das vorgestellt hat Gras made in German
in alle Welt verschenken der Potenzial
naja
das ist ja jetzt auch marketingmäßig
nicht so einfach ja da haben sich jetzt
ja in den letzten Jahren so ein paar
Sachen etabliert wie der schwarze
Afghane so dann dann kommen jetzt da so
so deutsche mit sowas neu um die Ecke
hier der braune Brandenburger ja
Sachsen ist Gang oder hier die die
güterslohe himmelflöte
ich meine klar das wäre schön ja warum
liefern die Deutschen immer nur Autos
oder Waffen ja warum nicht mal deutsches
krass ne das ballert auch
aber ich glaube wir können zumindest
alternation bald hoffe ich zumindest
dass sie so entwickelt eine eine
Botschaft transportieren nämlich dass
der deutsche im bekifften Zustand
leichter zu ertragen ist als ihn
besoffen
wahrscheinlich habe ich mir das
vorstellen in deiner DDR Jugend ich muss
fragen weil ich war nicht dabei hattet
ihr das Produkt oder habt ihr
stattdessen keine Ahnung Spreewaldgurken
geraucht oder was wie sagst du aus
das ist wieder so dieses typische ja
kann ich sagen nein
die Spreewaldgurken hatten wir nicht
geraucht
sondern die wurden gespritzt ja
und es gab super ganz harte Typen die
haben die wirklich auch gegessen
nein klar wurde irgendwie auch geraucht
da gab es dann so eine so eine
erzgebirgsmischung das war eine Melange
ja so Asbest Autoreifen
Dinkel und Gürtelrose ja hier vom
käferkombination hatte aber ich habe
keine Wirkung also Nebenwirkung oder
Schubert vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Audi Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los
du scheiß Pferd hey